[Music]
because if you get your sections too big
your hair won't be able to dry overnight
all right so now tomorrow morning all
you're gonna do is just take these out
but first I want to tell you why I
haven't uploaded in a while here comes
this freakin bee bee sting right here on
my face
my god girl I'm so over dating but they
don't know that there all done it's easy
quick and beautiful I'm so over dating
it's like all right now remember ladies
if you blow-dry your hair
[Music]
[Music]
interesting Mario but make it fashion
[Music]
hey Quinta you look great I love your
makeup thank you so much that's crazy
cuz I'm not even wearing wearing that
much
[Music]
oh come on okay maybe just go sexy on
him real quick
what the hell are you doing no time for
embarrassment it's just to make a little
fish face no this is my natural everyday
look and I want you guys to Hey oh we
did your makeup it looks nice yeah girl
doesn't even he lends a little bit
thicker but no no no no one will be able
to tell it is fine
you could not even I maybe I'm seeing
things so the rock flies off the truck
it hits my windshield my windshield
shatters I'm technically I can't hold
the truck liable because oh hi Quincy
hey crazy
I like the glitter and stuff thanks
anyway so I have to freaking pay for the
windshield myself
nice face Thanks
I live you look so kyo such a look what
foundation is it is it Fendi this looks
so good
there's a bit of a smudge though right
on your contour let me fix this euro but
I sing about butterfly as well was your
face hichy buddy
uh-huh oh you look dry and did you use
what's that stuff called primer learn
that from life of Kylie I lost my remote
anyway are you wearing it uh well we
have to go out too now you should go
take all that stuff off and then reapply
everything except for people who really
wear makeup do obey what you think about
it make it drop it crawl back I know
what's it doing but submit what's a cow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I just came to have a good time I pity
answer
[Music]
Hey ladies anybody wanna dance okay how
about you oh okay
[Music]